my name is Robert you Scofield I'm Jason
Harris our talk is titled wolfram player
and Wolfram engine for iOS we work in
the user interface department at Wolfram
research and we are part of the team
that built Wolfram player for iOS and so
I'll be talking demonstrating the
capabilities of the player going through
a lot of examples that think quickly
through its capabilities and then and
then I will give examples how to embed
our technology into your own iOS app
Thanks
all right good afternoon everybody my
name is Robert hey Scofield and along
with my colleague Jason Harris we're
going to talk today about some iOS
products we both work in the user
interface department and we are part of
the team that built the Wolfram player
for iOS but we didn't just build the
player app we built kind of a stack of
technologies that the player app uses
and later on in the talk I'm going to go
into details on how you can use the
Wolfram engine via our CDF kit SDK in
your own iOS applications but first I'm
gonna hand it off to Jason and he's
going to give you a run through the app
itself right ok so I've got to make sure
I leave enough time for Rob here so I'm
just gonna spin zip through some of the
some of the capabilities of the actual
native player for iOS so if you've been
to Nick and parts talk or Andre
mentioned this previously the the
Wolfram player now is at version 12.0
and standalone application it has a full
Wolfram engine embedded in here so it
has all the capabilities you'd normally
have on the desktop it's for it's
available for free on the App Store it
costs $10 to unlock interactivity and
any notebooks that are signed you can
you can fully interact with them so
let's go quickly zipping through some of
the examples to fully illustrate some of
the capabilities so in terms of
typesetting I along with Robyn parts of
the team have coated up a large bit of
the algorithms for typesetting and I can
confirm that a lot of the layout
algorithms are very similar on the
desktop and on this new core and so of
course we have you know subscripts and
superscripts infraction
boxes and square roots and all the
square roots there have you know they're
nicely paths draw and the vinculum are
all lined up you know complements you
know we have all the traditional form
typesetting binomials and fractions and
sums and styles and you know frames and
all the various different bits of frame
so here we have you know a grid box here
and I did the grid box of course a lot
of it and the the main desktop front end
in and and be light here this this new
core and I can you know say pretty
definitively that they show the version
on in this new core is actually superior
and in many sort of regards and here's
some examples of just you know the
complete characters you you know all
very symbols arrows characters as a
illustration of them here's some
template boxes for traditional form
typesetting and rotation boxes and those
are working okay so graphics all 2d
graphics if for you sue has implemented
a lot of these and so you you know you
can see a graphics of you know rasters
and here we see that you know the
background on a particular plot changes
we've got you know the graphics
primitives we've got a circle we've got
you know arcs and you know discs and
wedges and graphics group boxes line
boxes polygons boxes and you know
bayesian boxes and all the other various
2d primitives they're all fully
implemented in terms of 3d graphics
we've got it's actually kind of nice you
can you know set this thing sort of
spinning and move it around with two
fingers you can actually sort of move
this round into a sort of position the
controls are probably a little bit nicer
than they are actually on desktop
because you've got this to sort of
finger you know we can pan that around
and we can zoom it in and out and and
and move it as would like and of course
all the rest of you know parametric
plots and you know some sector charts
bark and bark paths look Brett so that
part is a former team member so yeah and
so and of course that's all built up in
terms of the primitives here we see you
know cones and you know cuboids and you
know cylinders and geometric
transformation boxes and graphics group
boxes and graphics group 3d boxes
complex boxes line boxes point clouds
polygons spheres and two boxes so
basically all 3d primitives are are
included well so so there's a few things
the bleeding edge in the desktop like
surface appearance as a new primitive
with shaders and stuff and
so that one of these things are then
ported we try and maintain parity with
the desktop and I'll talk about the the
differences in the versions in a second
so controls of course work and you know
since it has a full colonel embedded in
it as you see the slider you can't see
my finger but my finger is actually on
top of the knob the this little control
right here and so when I move this with
my finger I can't actually see it I'm
covering it up and so for the iPad
version we have this nice little tooltip
above that shows us what the value is
it's it's kind of nice and we might even
port this back to the desktop it makes a
nice sort of interaction there and of
course checkboxes work it's changing the
value of that dynamic there the pop-up
menu here will change the value of that
dynamic the slider goes out of range
here the we change the X to minus 1 here
it changes there and so on we have set
our bars we'll change the values radio
button bar radio button bars work you
know a locators of course you know we
can move this round it has this nice
little pop-up color sliders do their
thing Action menu boxes animators we can
speed that up a bit make that bounce
both ways and so on and so animators
work progress indicators slider to days
we can show and hides an axis there in
terms of controls input fields work and
we can type some stuff in that's a
non-continuous input field so when I
tapped out of the input field or I hit
enter it'll commit the results and of
course the continuous one works
continuously just like on the desktop ok
and so we have some you know here's a
tab view we can change the position of
the tabs and hyperlinks work and so we
could go off here to the demonstrations
website you know download this to the
desktop download it here in our device
get that take a look at it and go view
it in our player apples changed it so we
can't automatically just pop it open but
here would gogo and you know interact
with this you know particular thing and
it's it ok so that gives a quick zipping
through of controls I actually like to
talk about manipulate here and so here
let's let's start off with with some
point outs and bits to do with
manipulate here's the simplest
manipulate you can probably have and so
here we go and it's manipulating 0 2x
zero to 1 X's goes to 0 to 1 and right
now you'll notice that the actual
controls are placed down here and we
place the controls down here instead of
on top of that because if we place the
controls in the normal way that we do on
the desktop would be covering the
controls as we actually move our hand
and so it's nice to put them on this
raft down the bottom and of course as we
scroll out the manipulator screen it D
focuses and of course we just can have
multiple sorts of controls here that's
very nice and responsive and here's
another blog we can you know turn around
and animate that and see it animate
nicely as it is it moves around right
and of course you know these are all
spinnable and and here's a more complex
one and it works just as it is you'd
have on the desktop you know here's
there's an X in there that's you know
changing its perspective as we move it
okay so I'd like to move on to of course
the iPad is usually a great device for
consuming content on on you know there
is some creation of it people are trying
to make it as a laptop you know
substitute but but by and large we iPads
are or tablets or mobile devices are
used for consuming content so that
natural target market is of course
documents like this book chapter by Eric
Schultz from Pearson and and we use this
during the development of you know just
to test all the various features and so
of course in this book chapter they'll
explain various bits about you know line
integrals here and you and the student
can click on it and take a look and go
oh that's what a line integral sort of
is you know show the surface and so on
and so this is probably a bit more of
the target market for for for students
and other you know electronic books
along with all of your other notebooks
and of course here you know he's got
solutions to problems and notes and and
so on and it's it's it's butter smooth
in terms of its scrolling around it's
very fast and efficient ok so I'd like
to actually point out so this timer how
is this related is this means we've only
got 16 minutes left so Wow okay
I'd better go faster so so the native
hat ok so it we've talked about opening
we've seen it and nichkhun and parts
talk about how to get documents on you
can get for them from your cloud account
you know back here there's a cloud
account right
here and you can see the various
different things you can go on to it and
take a look and so we'll go down here to
our display here so we can open
documents from anywhere with email
iCloud Dropbox Google Drive side loading
and airdrop right quickly okay so let me
point out in particular that that this
is fully there this is fully native and
it has a full wolfram engine embedded in
it so the interaction between the front
end of the kernel is instantaneous you
don't have to worry about any lag for
network connectivity and more
importantly we don't actually have to
worry about any browser compatibility
does this work on Firefox does it look
different on Chrome so on and there's
there's a lot of things we can do
natively that it's just sort of
impossible to do on the browser and this
isn't detract from our cloud product
yawn and stuff done amazing job but it's
very difficult and so when we have a
native app we can do a lot of things
that are appropriate to the platform in
better ways some things we've made so so
this is that actually I'm launching it
I'll just sort of step forward we've got
this entirely new core and of course we
can deploy it to different sort of
platforms one of these platforms is iOS
and so on the iOS version we've actually
made the we've done iOS specific things
like you know our finger size touch
targets are bigger and some of the some
they look a little bit bigger so you
make sure they're not fat fingered and
you can touch on them we've got you know
pinch to zoom as you've seen the
manipulate controls are in a different
placement and so here here's just a few
of the other ones so we've added some
stuff to the this version of the kernel
that's running on on this on this device
and one of those sorry here is a touch
position and so of course you've got
Mouse position on the desktop but we
don't have a mouse and so as I put
multiple fingers on here you see
multiple different sort of touches that
are going on so that's one thing another
thing is the touch screen control
placement you'll see here in this
manipulate right here this touch screen
control placement goes on the right so
we've put the actual the the raft of
controls on the right so that's that's
adapted for for for tablets and of
course I've mentioned sliders you see
this nice sort of tooltip that goes on
top one other thing that we've got is
this ghost slider so you can sort of see
there's two thumbs right there and so
it's kind of nice that the there's the
main slot the main thumb that the the
front
and here are our NB Light or player says
it should be but of course the slider is
one two three in steps of one so it can
only take the values in the kernel one
two and three and so this goes thumb
shows where the kernel thinks that the
value is versus where the the front end
where the our player sort of thinks it
is and so this is kind of nice we
originally put this in because we
thought our our version was going to be
too slow on the iPad it turns out it's
actually a lot faster we internally use
and our formatting passes we use these
crypto hashes and Merkle trees a little
bit like blockchain some really cool hip
tech technologies and it's actually
highly dominated by the drawing speed
not actually are sort of formatting
speed so things are more efficient in
this new core and it's it's it's very
fast and so we've kept this goes thumb
around and in fact it's something we'll
probably port back to the main desktop
as we go on and of course our locators
here as you see it's got this nice
little blow-up so of course I'm covering
it with my finger and so we can see it
nicely okay so it's actually talking
I'll mention here that this is a whole
new core it took us quite a while but
Rob originally started this effort he
worked in the system layer system
interface layer on the main desktop and
so he designed this core he started it
off with making the goal of making this
core very transportable when we can put
it on different architectures Android
Linux Windows Mac iOS and whatever and
so we've built this core and be light
that's that's highly it's very modern
hip and cool and uses its fully
multi-threaded from the ground up and of
course multi-threading is upon us if you
take a look at for instance maybe $500
will buy a Rison now which has got 12
cores 24 threads or core Intel will buy
you eight cores and and 16 threads for a
simple sort of desktop now so
multi-threading is really an our our
wheelhouse and happily our new core is
fully multi-threaded and let me just
show you a demo of that I'm going to
switch to a development player where
I've turned on this feature called and
complete formatting and I'll just load
up this notebook this slow loading up
okay you see it actually loads very fast
and right now all of these dynamics
which I've got a pause of one are
actually filling in on all the various
different multiple threads and it just
loaded the notebook up and if I loaded
this on a normal desktop if Rob shows it
later on you can see this will take 15
seconds and old go line by line by line
and just shows you the full
multi-threading sort of nature on on
this device in our core okay so if we go
back to the native player here and I
gotta make sure I give Rob some time to
speak so we've got this whole new core
and Rob is actually going to talk about
the CBF kit of how it's actually sort of
built we've got Zen be light and we've
got this kernel engine and it's the the
nd light it's got these other sorts of
course the current limitations of course
even saying that this is it's fully
multi-threaded it actually turns out
that for parallel tools apple will on
the iPad the player it's nothing to do
with the core but on the restriction of
this player were only allowed a single
process instance space so we were only
allowed one kernel when you quit this
process it quits the kernel as well and
so we can't do parallel computation on
this device but of course the core can
do it absolutely fine or you can call
out to other remote kernels saving it's
a player so we don't save notebook
programming notebook yet no selection
move those kinds of things are a work in
progress some other limitations and of
course I'll mention of course the big
one Java Apple says no on here iOS
devices so we need to have other other
techniques and so we can use URL fetch
and URL executed okay I could I could
talk about some of the other features
but I need to leave Rob some time I'll
just mention you know side loading this
is a way to sort of get files onto your
devices and indeed you can put a package
that simulate peer to peer here's a
package I'm not going to go through and
illustrate all the various bits I'm just
going to give you the summary it's got
local packages on here we've got some
sort of cloud connectivity I can do some
I can load a package via the cloud I can
when do I load it I can load it on first
displaying it or if I initialization and
this application I'm just going to show
you is and peer-to-peer lending very
quickly normally and lending you've got
a bank but I'm peer-to-peer lending you
have no bank you've just got a lender
and borrowers and so we micro
fractionalize alone so they might this
borrower might have learning twenty
thousand dollars in each of these
lenders lends like five dollars and then
over time the borrower pays it back and
you know not all lenders have to not
like the color of BA rotors money and so
they might not do it and so the ideas of
course they've got no central
organization and if
financially collapsed you don't have run
on banks and it's other sorts of bets
and we can go and visualize this so the
point of this is there's a package
behind here it's four hundred lines of
code so it's not a one-liner but it's
not you know 20,000 lines of code but we
can actually put this all on and we can
actually load this up on our device and
when I click on this you'll just see
quickly it'll come up in a loading
loading loading at loaded the package so
it loaded this package that simulates
peer-to-peer things and we can you know
select some grades of investments here
and we can just sort of set it to
running here and we can actually sort of
see the whole it illustrates a few
things that actually having a complex
package on on our player and selecting
some grades there's some persistence
locally on the on the device and we can
do complicated things okay I'm gonna
have to then move back to handing off to
Rob here let me just conclude with the
summary before Rob starts talking about
CDF kit so we have a fully native player
for the iOS it's a whole new engine we
can and and I guess the real challenge
of our times now is since we've got
these cooling features we need to
actually unify these with the desktop
and we need to marry these together and
that's what we're engaged in of bringing
back some of these new modern things
that are really very neat and this
players of course just one incantation
of this we have it you know compiling
we've got a version of the front-end on
the Macintosh which is using this core
which is you know different and we're
continuing to flesh out the
functionality and unification so I'll
hand it back to Rob for talking about
CDF kit thank you very much Jason so
right so the the good news is that not
only can you benefit from our efforts in
downloading the wolfram player app for
iOS very soon you will be able to embed
that technology into your own iOS apps
if you'd like to do so we have this
product called wolfram engine that is
available in this slide basically came
straight from the Wolfram com / Engine
website it's available for Mac Windows
and Linux right now and we hope very
soon to have a fourth button up there
that says iOS and what that is going to
do is it's going to give you something
you can download to your machine and you
can start a development project that
includes our technology in an iOS app ok
so this diagram Jason showed earlier the
player itself is kind of a not the major
part of all of this effort the the CDF
kit that the player is built on top of
is where we have spent most of the time
and effort in making this happen
and this is a framework with an
objective-c interface and we use that
the exact same interface in our player
app that we're going to make available
to any of you so when you download CDF
kit you get something looks like this
you get a couple of directories full of
frameworks to link against there's some
documentation there's some example
projects so the first thing you do when
you want to build a project using CDF
kit there's a couple of project wide
changes you need to make in a new Xcode
project for iOS first is you need to set
your framework search path so it can
find our frameworks next you need to add
some stuff here which to the project
what this does is when you're building
the project it copies the frameworks to
the correct location this is something
you only need to setup once and then you
can completely forget about it and you
can use this exact code right here you
don't need to write it yourself
next we have the classes of CDF Kidd the
first thing we're going to start with is
something called cdf session this is
just a basic singleton pattern from
objective-c or Swift if you've done iOS
development that should look very
familiar
nothing very complicated then if you
want to display notebook content in your
app there's two classes you need to look
at the first of which is called CDF
document and with that class you can
create an empty file and change its
contents at any point you can load a
file from disk and then you pass that
document on to CDF view controller and
what that does is it takes the document
and it creates a UI view for your iOS
application that you can do whatever you
want with you can embed it in you know
your view controllers UI view you can
have it take up the entire screen you
can have it take up a fraction of the
screen and just to point out here there
are various options you can pass to it
this one right here just enables
scrolling so there are some cases where
you want your notebook content to fit a
rectangular area in some cases where you
just want to display a notebook and have
it scroll up and down so as you've been
seeing in the player app which I'm using
at the moment we have scrolling content
so this is the option that we use to get
that so in addition to displaying
notebook content you can also evaluate
expressions using Wolfram language
expressions using Wolfram engine and the
way you do that is you create objects of
this type CDF expert and there's a few
different ways of doing that you can
create symbols and functions and
integers manually you can have a string
of text and parse those into an
expression and once you have an
expression you can pass that off to an
evaluator and the evaluator takes the
input expression and at some point later
when that expression finishes it can
optionally call a callback
to tell you that it's finished and tell
you what the output of that expression
is so there are some cases where you
don't really care about the output if
you're just using it to set x equals
five you don't care about the output of
that so you can just ignore the handler
and there are some cases where you want
to be notified when the evaluation
finishes so let's just look at a few
examples these are in included with the
SDK just to show you it's not that much
work to create a new document wrap a
view controller around it and then add
it to your view that's three lines of
code and this is an objective-c the same
code will work in Swift just accounting
for the different syntaxes of the two
languages
so let's just take a quick look at this
app what it actually does there are
three views to pay attention to one is
the text field up at the top this is
basic iOS programming there's a button
over there and then there's this big
white rectangle which is the CDF view so
when I hit the compute button all it's
going to do is evaluate the text that is
in the input field and then it will put
the result of that in the notebook so
well whatever okay so we can evaluate
whatever we want we can display whatever
we want
there are other cases if we look at this
one for example that's strange
all right little problem there this is
kind of a more traditional iOS
application with the the master detail
view we have a list of salts this was
all data that was generated using
Wolfram language code I exported it to a
file I included that file with the app
and so this is a graphics 3d box
expression that was generated using
Wolfram language code and so whenever I
just tap on one of these items on the
left hand side it loads a 3d graphics
box and displays it on the right hand
side and then one other quick example
show is that this one the other examples
were written in objective-c this one was
written in Swift all it does is display
a notebook that's included with the
application bundle but this is a very
very small amount of code in Swift that
it takes to do that this is all of the
CDF kit related code in that application
it's three lines load the document
create the view controller add the sub
view so that's all there is to that you
think would be worth showing the Xcode
yeah all of these all of this code right
here is included in the examples
directory with the CDF kit which we hope
to make available for download as soon
as possible